Basketball Hall of Famer Charles Barkley
Happy New Year Charles my brother right
back at you right back at you you're the
first person I thought of when when I'm
like okay who can I get to call in and
maybe give some thoughts remembrances of
David Stern when was the first time you
ever crossed paths with the commissioner
Charles I think part of the night before
the draft he might have came by and said
hello to us guys but the first time I
was spending the time you know obviously
it's a big deal you see or today when
tears shake hands that's a pretty cool
thing it's like you you made it hmm when
you walk across that stage and you state
the commissioners hand and and it's four
that's pretty cool but obviously you
know I've been in the NBA over 30 years
now and I've had a lot of opportunity to
spend time with Commissioner Stern most
of it was really really good some of it
was really really bad when I screwed up
but I tell people other than Magic
Johnson Larry Bird he's the most
important person in NBA history you know
people forget you know you know rich
we've been living in the last few years
for everything it's been perfect and
everybody making a crapload of money but
you know when he first got to the NBA
des the average salary was $200,000 now
the average salary is over seven million
dollars you know I'm looking at some of
these numbers that you know it was a
hundred and some million dollar [ __ ]
there's nine four five point five
billion dollar [ __ ] a year and you go
back to the dream team all the TV deals
games is not on tape delay anymore you
can't even put into words what this man
meant took the entire NBA legacy just
like I say we've been so profitable and
so big for the last thirty years people
get when he took over it was considered
a not a good lead drug-infested too many
black guys and people he took over this
league and made it what it is today
which is amazing so when when people
talk about David Stern the first thing
that they
mention is how he took the platform at
the NBA built it or helped shape it and
then handed it off to the players to be
front and center how did he do that
Charles as a player that obviously wound
up front and center like you well I
think the main thing is you know we're a
little bit different than in an NFL they
always worry about the shield and you
know they don't want their players to
step out but he made the players like
saying he can listen I've said this not
and I Maddy Johnson and Larry Bird saved
the NBA they're the two most important
players in history and David maximize
put them in a position put all those
players in a position where we could
make the most money if we make more
money than any other athletes anywhere I
mean you think about that we make more
money than any other sports franchise
players in any other sport and it's all
guaranteed and we got a great revenue
sharing model that he came up with he
was the first guy to come up with drug
policies you can't put into words what
he meant for the NBA I mean it's pretty
amazing and I came in and with him my
first year in 1984 you know you know
which I gotta tell you a funny story I'm
clamp on December 6 I'm playing with dr.
J Mosley Loma reach he's a guru Tony I
remember the first time our NBA player
made a million dollars we were walking
around high-fiving each other I mean
that's how crazy you know it was
we never thought a guy would be making a
million dollars when Magic Johnson sign
for 25 years or 25 million dollars
me and Moses dr. J and all those guys my
recent Andrew and we're high-fiving each
other because we could not believe that
a mpa player could actually make a
million dollars and look at where he
left the league when he retired and I
just look at it today and
it means you can sit there and say wow
he did a great job great it's not a good
enough words to describe what this man
put all of us in position to what we got
the greatest lives ever today and then
obviously when when things might have
taken a turn
he was always front and center as well
and by a turn you've mentioned magic a
few times when magic left the NBA
because he was HIV positive and the way
that Stern handled it along with his
return you were right there again in the
middle of all that can you walk me
through how Stern handled everything and
some of the issues that he handled in a
manner that got the NBA and obviously
magic back together again you know I
don't know all the parameters I'm not
going to act like I was in on those
discussions just standing up for magic
because listen nobody knew a lot about
the AIDS virus back then a lot of people
were stupid they couldn't see long as
you in the same room with people or
shake their hands you can catch the
virus which is totally incorrect and to
embrace magic going back you know the
all-star game the dream team it really
took away the stigma of the AIDS virus
and it took somebody of his caliber to
make that happen but I will tell you
this I've been watching and reading for
the last obviously 24 hours or more and
one thing that came to my mind you see
that everybody talks about how Stern he
could be he had the perfect right name
or stern right but I've never heard one
person and I said this yesterday on NBA
TV I had to go meet with him when I
screwed up hardly three or four times
and man this dude he make a grown man
want to cry when he's yelling at you but
the one thing I've never heard anybody
say is he never has done it publicly
like me and Ernie and
and the guys at TNT like he came down a
few times and just shoot their ass up
really good really good
but he always did it behind closed doors
like every time I screwed up he got on
me really really good but he always gave
me a hug or shook my hand is he fine
he's just got to do better grow up grow
up grow up and I've been watching
everybody who said that man he was a
tough boss yes he was but I never hunted
somebody that he embarrassed him
publicly which is really one of the keys
to being a great boss and a great leader
when you run a billion-dollar
corporation like I'm in fact awaited us
and I've been watching those two movies
the last couple years and like you've
got to be difficult and make difficult
decision when you like run a major major
corporation but comparing Davis during
the Steve Jobs I know that's a little
unfair but David Stern never got I've
never seen him acknowledge or get on
somebody's case and I've never heard
anybody over the last few days talk
about yo yeah he was talking to stop
yourself but I've never heard somebody
say he embarrassed me publicly before
which is an amazing talent well take me
inside the room were you and him sitting
down where he's getting on you making
you feel like maybe you wanted a what we
in there I thought I thought my name was
Charles Barkley ml or sob like in like
you sitting there and and he's yelling
and there's nothing like first of all I
was wrong so it ain't like I can fight
back and he's telling me about you you
can't do this you can't do this I know
it happened it happened and then that
lasts an hour or less hmm and then he
comes over and shake your hand give you
a hug they hate anything knows it this
is over I'm not gonna bring it up again
you know how some people when you screw
up they bring it up every time you see
something wrong no he says these are all
individual things but he always gave me
a hug and shook my hand and every time I
saw him I always told the last time I
saw him was at the NBA
all the pain ceremony and always in my
day man thank you for everything you did
for me every single thing because you
know rich if it was a basketball I'm not
gonna sit here a lot and tell you I was
gonna be great academically I'll have no
idea what I would have be it
but basketball has given me every single
thing in my life every single thing in
my life and I love basketball for that
reason and like I say I go back to we're
high-fiving each other when guys made a
million dollars now you got guys making
two hundred three hundred million
dollars it is all because the
Commissioner Stern Charles Barkley a
couple more minutes left with him here
on the Rich Eisen show so what do you
think is obviously that that that's a
big lasting legacy for for players just
in terms of what what he was as you said
as a guy who cared about players Michael
Ray Richardson said that the three
strikes and you're out rule that sent
him away from the league saved his life
I mean that's the sort of stuff you hear
about David Stern today Charles well I
think that I heard nothing anything but
positives and listen legacy yeah he
could be he was a tough demand involved
but everybody runs a major corporation
has got to be a tough demanding boss but
the difference is all these I'm reading
some of these condolences and Twitter
things is nothing but respect and love
for this man like yeah even though there
because there's times I remember one
time when we were on strike
and he came in he said hey if you guys
don't take this deal we're not gonna
play basketball and I'm and and he's
we're not gonna play basketball so we're
gonna get the TV Bunny and y'all are not
gonna play this year so he says that and
I hear the guys so we get we go back out
we meet we like oh he's bluffing oh he's
bluffing that's what this sound like he
was bluffing to me so there we go all
stew
right so then we get together for we
missed half the cities that I have to
season we get together and we say hey
we're gonna take that deal you know what
he said rich but oh no no no no that was
the deal I offered child two months ago
before y'all screwed up my season and
you could have heard a pin drop in the
room he's like oh no no no no you're not
gonna get that deal anymore
that's the deal I offer child over the
summer before y'all screwed up my damn
season and I'm just kind of like the two
talking of like oh we I think we are
really screwed up right here but hey it
always worked out good for the owners
and the players I mean you like I say if
you look at all the sports we are that
highest-paid we got the best
endorsements and for him turning the
league not turn the league over to the
players letting the players be
individuals and market themselves a
certain way we should all be thankful to
Commissioner Stern hey Charles before I
let you go I'd be remiss if I didn't ask
you how you think the NFL playoffs are
gonna play out now that they're where we
start this weekend what do you like I
think I think it's going to be one of
the most fascinating I think it's gonna
be one of the most fascinating playoffs
ever you know I think that it might be
it looks like it might be the end other
Patriots dynasty I tell you what how
Lamar Jackson is gonna have like his
first real playoff run an NFC man this
the Saints the Packers the San Francisco
has been amazed and to go in and see out
or win that game and a must-win
situation because that might that's one
of the toughest places to plate no doubt
got my homes in Kansas City I tell you
what this is going to be I cannot wait
to watch the playoffs this year
first time in a long time I think it's
really truly up for grabs it is it's
wide open I think any 12 can make a
lasting imprint for for much of January
and certainly obviously some into
February but if you had to choose who
winds up in Miami for the Super Bowl AFC
versus NFC I'll ask for that what do you
got the Green Bay Packers I put that
against the Kansas City Chiefs Wow
that's the Moldy so you're not going any
of the 1cg like 2 to 2 seats you like
that well I think that I just I do I
just think hey listen I think Aaron is
amazing and I think Patrick is amazing
and that's just listen I lost every
playoff game last year so I'm not saying
that you're right but that's entirely
possible
I mean that is in notably I love every
single game in the playoffs last year so
I'm I'm scared this year I actually
might sit these playoffs out and
generally I'm not even I'm not even
joking
I lost every single game in the playoffs
last year well many of you do that is a
minute you're gonna get them all right
Charles I don't want to you know put put
too much in your head right now but
that's entirely possible
you know I'm lying - because if there's
a football game I probably don't read
off this is gonna be fun to watch
I can't wait for Saturday night whatever
they get started that's right Charles
thanks for the time really appreciate it
happy New Year to you and yours love you
man thanks for the call love you too
brother hey everybody out there you got
it thanks again that's Charles Barkley
for more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR Live or download the Rich Eisen
show app